we're asked to multiply 5/6 times 2/3
and then simplify our answer so let's
just multiply these two numbers so we
have 5 over 6 times 2 over 3 now when
you're multiplying fractions it's
actually a pretty straightforward
process you just multiply the new
numerator the numerator of the product
is just the product of the two
numerators or your new top number is the
product of the other two top numbers so
our new the numerator and our product is
just 5 times 2 so it's equal to 5 times
2 over 6 times 3 over 6 times 3 which is
equal to 5 times 2 is 10 and 6 times 3
is 18 so it's equal to 10 18s and you
could view this as either two thirds of
five sixths or 5/6 of two thirds
depending on how you want to think about
it and this is a right answer it is 10
18s but when you look at these two
numbers you immediately or you might
immediately see that they share some
common factors they're both divisible by
two so if we want it in the lowest terms
we want to divide them both by two so
divide 10 by 2 divide 18 by 2 and you
get 10 divided by 2 is 5 18 divided by 2
is 9 now you could have essentially done
this step earlier on you could have done
it actually before we did the
multiplication you could done it over
here you could have said well I have a 2
in the numerator and I have something
divisible by 2 in the denominator so let
me divide the numerator by 2 and this
becomes a 1 let me divide the
denominator by 2 and this becomes a 3
and then you have 5 times 1 is 5 and 3
times 3 is 9 so it's really the same
thing we did right here we just did it
before we actually took the product you
could actually do it right here so if
you did it right over here you'd say
well look these are eventually going to
6 times 3 is eventually going to be the
denominator 5 times 2 is that eventually
going to be the NAM the numerator so
let's divide the numerator by 2 so this
will become a 1 let's divide the
denominator by 2 this is divisible by 2
so that'll become a 3 and it'll become 5
times 1 is 5 and 3 times 3 is 9
so either way you do it'll work if you
do it this way it kind of you get to see
the fact things factored out a little
bit more so it's usually easier to
recognize what's divisible by what or
you could do it at the end and put
things in lowest terms